-You know our next guest
from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
which airs this Saturday
on NBC with host Parl--
excuse me -- host Paul Rudd
and musical guest Charli XCX.
His new show "Saturday Morning
All Star Hits!"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Welcome to "Smash." I'm Skip!
-And I'm Treybor. And we're...
-[ Echoing ] Lost!
-We got to get back
because we can't miss
an all-new "Strongimal."
-Yeah, 'cause
I do a voice on it.
-Oh, yeah, that's --
that's this week.
-Yep, guess the dudes who make
cartoonarooskies
think my voice
is totally zuh-zi-zas.
-What does that mean?
-Hey, if you have to zas,
then you'll never zas!
-Please welcome back to the show
Kyle Mooney, everybody.
Hello, Kyle.
-Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kyle, I say this so sincerely.
I've always felt
like you're someone
whenever you do something
on "SNL," I feel like,
oh, you have such an authentic
and voice that is true to you.
And yet I have
never seen anything
that is more hyper-cent--
like hyper-specifically
Kyle Mooney than this show.
You must be thrilled
with how it turned out.
-I feel great, and yeah,
that is the thing
I feel like everybody
is saying, is "This is so you,"
which is -- I can't tell
how I feel about that
because it's all based
on children's cartoons.
But at the same time, like, yes,
this is the stuff that I love
and I feel so great about it.
-I mean, it's basically you play
twins who are hosting
a Saturday morning cartoon block
and they are '80s and '90s
cartoons that again,
are so -- it's an homage, right?
I mean, it's safe to say these
are the things you love deeply.
-So much. I do think
it could be an issue.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, like, this is my life.
This is -- And the whole --
The show is presented
as if it's taped off TV.
So you're getting, like,
commercials and news clips.
And I play
all of these characters.
We got to make these cartoons,
but seriously, this is the stuff
that I feel like
I've been studying for this
since 1988
or something like that.
-Now, was this a case
where you had to go back
and try to remember
what those cartoons were like?
Or have you been watching them
continuously into adulthood?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no. I do every day.
I have a pretty massive VHS
collection, actually,
and this is --
-This is your VHS.
For people who think you're,
like, lying, these are like,
actually...
[ Laughter ]
You have and you will
just have people over
right, fellow castmates,
friends in New York and say,
"Hey, you just grab a tape,
my friend."
-Yeah, well, I mean,
like, you and I overlapped.
Do you remember that?
-I do. Yeah, of course.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It was great, by the way
just to be around you.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah, my first year,
I don't know.
How would you describe
"Saturday Night Live" as a job?
Hectic, stressful, I don't know.
What are the -- How do you...?
-Well, yeah, I think those
are really accurate,
and then especially starting
at "SNL" is the worst haunting
feeling in the world
because you have a day
where you think
"I've joined comedy royalty,"
and then your second day,
you're like, "They're going to
cut my head off."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I love saying
that too, just the whole
"joining comedy royalty" line.
[ Laughter ]
But you're right. It only lasts
for 24 hours.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah, no.
Like, my first year
after the after parties
on Saturday nights
at like, you know, 4:30, 5:30
in the morning,
I would typically have
some friends
from the show come over
and and we would just --
I would say "Pick
anything off the VHS wall"
and we would just smoke hookah
and then watch like
"Rainbow Brite"
or something like that.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the only thing
that could make me feel good.
-Yeah.
Last time you were here,
you brought a bag full of VHS
tapes just to give us
a sense of the flavor
of your work, of your library.
-Yes.
-As you like to say.
-Yes, yeah.
-So I'm going to just
pull these out.
Thank you
for sending these over.
This is the perfect bag for them
to be in.
-I will say, Seth,
just so you --
most of my tape--
the tapes you saw in that photo,
those have all been moved
to Los Angeles, basically.
So now my apartment
in New York is empty.
But I will open up
drawers or cabinets
and still find
leftover piles of VHS.
There's just too -- There's
too many, and it's always --
It doesn't make me feel great
about who I am,
but I wanted to show you
what I have and truly,
like, this was on Tuesday night
I opened up my cabinet
and these are some
of the things I found.
-Alright, so tell us
a little bit about
"The Miracle of the Staircase."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's just
a really good movie
about that spiral staircase.
[ Laughter ]
-The cover is kind of
giving a lot of it away?
-Yes. And so I do feel bad
for the --
Maybe you should
put it away now, because yeah,
once you get to the...
It's a good movie, guys, and
you're going to want to see it.
[ Laughter ]
-This one. Alright.
Well, so this one,
this is, I guess,
an instructional video.
This is -- What's this one here?
-"Kittens to Cats."
[ Laughter ]
Again, something I feel
like everybody already knows.
-Yeah.
I want everybody to picture
who you think the woman
who stars in this is
and then tell me
if you thought it was her.
[ Laughter ]
-Ann Childers.
-One of the greats.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, now, I feel like
there's got to be some --
Tell me a little bit more
about "Kick Time!"
-"Kick Time!"
Fun and fitness with
Kirby the Clown
and the "Kick Time" kids.
-Yeah, he is a real clown.
I mean,
not just a clown in behavior
like, a full child clown.
It seems like I wouldn't --
I don't know if I'd want
to learn kicking from a clown.
[ Laughter ]
-Kirby's different.
-Oh, this is good,
because this seems to be
if your kid is hyper-specific
in their wants.
They probably wouldn't even
believe this exists as a film.
[ Laughter ]
-"I Wanna Be a Ship Captain."
This was --
So, you say hyper-specific,
but for me,
like every other kid
I went to elementary school with
was like, "Hey."
[ Laughter ]
"We got to do it."
This was the goal.
-Right.
It's like one of us can't afford
a ship, but if we chip in...
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly what I said.
-Oh, my gosh.
Now, I can't believe what this
is promising is even possible
because this is telling you
they can teach you a thing
in five minutes.
Kyle, you've obviously
had five minutes.
Does this mean that you can do
what this tape says you can do?
-Yes, I can do the Macarena
and I can also get mad.
-You also what?
-Can get mad!
[ Laughter ]
I like -- Now, if you --
What does the front say there?
-The front says,
"Learn the Macarena
in five minutes with Yazmina."
-Yeah, so I was --
So, if you look at the back,
I noticed this
one thing about it.
Can you read the portion
where Yazmina is referenced?
-Yeah, sure. Uh...
"It's infectious and sexy.
In this video, model
and dance instructor Yazmina
will show you the basic moves
and then move on
to some fun variations."
-Yeah, I just -- I don't know
if you can see it,
but Yazmina is in quotes
on the back.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So I don't know if this is
what we need to know
about Yazmina.
It seems like on the front,
she's presented as
the Macarena queen we all know.
But on the back, we're like...
You know?
-Are you saying maybe
on the day of, the real Yazmina
didn't show?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not saying anything.
-Can I tell --
There's two other things
I just noticed on the back.
It says, "As a special bonus,
Yazmina also
demonstrates the steps
for the --" in quotes --
"'Dirty Macarena.'"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-A sexy new version
that's on the upswing.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we're still --
Everybody's still doing
that one.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're right.
The Macarena was like a real,
you know, flash in the pan.
But the Dirty Macarena,
I feel like,
had some real staying power.
[ Laughter ]
-Seth, when you just talk about
it, I kind of...
Images come into my head that,
you know, maybe aren't
appropriate for the audience.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, there are two things
I wanted to ask you about
because again, they really
seem true to the era.
The kids' names,
the twins' names are Skip.
That one seems pretty
on the nose.
And then Treybor.
-Right.
-Were you very happy
when you came up with Treybor?
-Yeah. I mean, like, I think
it started as Skip and Trey,
and then it was truly just like,
"Maybe it's Treybor?"
And then it was like, "Yep, it's
going to be Skip and Treybor."
-It was like,
"Maybe it's Treybor
and we all call it a day?"
-Yeah, exactly.
-Also the catchphrase
"za-zi-zas,"
that really felt
like '90s morning TV to me.
-Zuh-zi-zas.
-Oh, sorry, I apologize.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's cool.
The Internet's not going
to be happy about that.
But you're fine.
[ Laughter ]
Zuh-zi-zas, yeah,
that's one of Skip's things,
and, like, we just wanted
to come up with
the best phrase
and that was our attempt.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think anyone's
going to argue with zuh-zi-zas
being the best phrase.
Hey, congrats again.
-Maybe Yazmina.
-Yeah. Oh! Yazmina!
Hey, thank you so much
for being here, man.
The show is fantastic.
Congratulations.
-Thanks so much, buddy.
Take care.
-Kyle Mooney, everybody.
"Saturday Morning
All Star Hits!"
is streaming now on Netflix,
and don't miss "Saturday Night
Live" this weekend.